it wasn't easy for Christian Bale to
prepare for director James Mangold's
Ford versus Ferrari but it was worth the
effort looper recently spoke with Ford
versus Ferrari stunt coordinator Robert
Nagel about how he made the veteran
actor road ready here's the truth behind
bales intense training for the pake
to teach Bale had a drive like a real
racer Nagle sent the former Dark Knight
to the Bondurant high performance
driving school in Arizona
for seven days Bale spent seven hours on
the track learning how to drive thanks
to lessons from Nagle's hand-picked
instructor but that was only part two
bales education and there was a reason
why Bondurant was the place bailed at
his first phase of bored vs. Ferrari
prep Nagel explained part of the reason
I picked Bondurant was that Bob
Bondurant was an icon from that era and
was a big part of that gt40 program two
years before Ken miles is history-making
performance at the 1966 automobile
events race car driver Bob Bondurant
completed 334 laps at the 1964 24 Hours
of LeMans like miles Vonda Roth was
driving a car designed by Carol Shelby
the engineer whom Matt Damon plays in
Ford versus Ferrari just shut your mouth
and let me do my thing
all right it was enough to win the GT
class at the event but not the overall
race naturally a Ferrari came in first
for a full week Bondurant regaled veil
and Nagel with stories from the Ford
versus Ferrari era of the mid-1960s
Nagel estimated that balaam Bondurant
chattered for 4 or 5 hours a day de
Nagel surprised Bondurant was also close
friends with miles and had plenty of
insights to share about the late star
Nagel dished the information that bale
was able to get from bob was amazing it
was an almost surreal experience to be
able to sit down with this guy and
listen to his stories it was phenomenal
the instructors at the Bondurant
high-performance driving school er top
class but at the end of Bale's training
behind the wheel Nagel had to hop in a
car to see the actor's progress for
himself it was during this final exam of
sorts that Bale was really put to the
test
eze Nagel joined bail on the track and
intentionally placed pressure on him to
see how well he could hold his composure
and focus on the road if you're gonna
push a piece of machinery to the limit
and expect it to hold together you have
to have some sense of where that limit
is Nagel shared the last day of training
we finished in real racecars one of the
tests that I do to whomever I'm training
is to see how well they stay focused to
see if I can distract them if they start
paying more attention to my car than
they are their own car then mistakes
start to happen Nagel didn't go easy on
bail just because he's a big-name actor
he admitted quotes i hounded him pretty
hard
I was inches off his gearbox and trying
to fill his mirrors left and right doing
everything I could to distract him
according to Nagel Bale managed to keep
his cool and complete the task without
any punch he passed the test with flying
colors and quotes never bobbled once
Nagel praised bales professionalism
during training he admitted he's
hands-down the best actor I've ever
trained coming from a pro like Nagel
that's quite a compliment all of that
training paid off big when it came time
to shoot poured versus Ferrari thanks to
his extensive training Bale knew exactly
which car was supposed to be doing
during poured vs. Ferraris Racing's
allowing him to react accordingly while
driving additionally his work at the
Bondurant high-performance driving
school actually led to some real time
behind the wheel on screen as Nagel
shared with looper because of the
training we did with him I felt very
comfortable putting Christian in the car
so he did Nagel revealed that the tie
and Ford versus Ferrari when you see
miles quote come screaming into the pits
and jump out of the car or jump into the
car and merge into traffic that's going
100 150 miles an hour aren't fake and
they're not the work of a stuntman
either Nagle confessed that's Christian
you can't fake that
some of the cars used in the movie were
remarkably close to the real thanks to
creating an even greater sense of
authenticity Nagle explained there's a
company called super performance and
they're actually licensed to make what
they call continuation copies of the
gt40 we had a few of those yes that
means the cars you see in the movie have
the same engine a Ford 427 is the one
that miles actually drove and yes it was
just as impressive and fun to handle and
niggles words it was quotes quite a
beast drive and we can only imagine Ford
versus Ferrari is in theaters now check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff or coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one